21 million 393,122
followers across all platforms for
Leila, Sharon, and me in the ACQ brands.
And I want to break down how to build a
personal brand in 2026, both leveraging
AI, but more importantly in spite of AI,
and how you can actually prove yourself
as somebody that people will want to
listen to. And so, I think the big thing
that has to be understood in AI is that
AI will not equally disrupt all
creators. And so, creators actually sit
on this continuum. You have low risk,
and then you have high risk.
So, how can you have a high-risk creator
or low-risk creator? Well, it depends on
what is being asked of the consumer. So,
for example, if you consume a meme or
you consume a stand-up comedy clip,
the risk that you have is just the time
that you're putting into consuming the
clip, and the product of that creator is
the clip itself. It's self-contained.
Meaning, when you consume it, if you
laugh, the value's already delivered.
You have a complete cycle. And so, these
fall under the category of entertainers.
And so, entertainers, and I define
entertainment as one thing, which is the
objective of the content is to be
consumed. So, if you think about a
perfect retention curve, if 100% of
people watch 100% of a video, you would
have a video that would go ultra ultra
viral, right? But there's nothing after
that. It's just you consumed it, you
have been entertained.
So then, what are the other parts on
this continuum?
So, the next one you would have would be
what I could consider a B2C educator.
So, what does that look like?
Now, to be fair, do you have to be only
one of these things? Of course not.
You're going to vary along this
continuum. It's not like there's a box
that you're like, "I'm only this or I'm
only this." The different types of
content you make may correspond with
different parts on this continuum, and
you also might even have within the same
piece of content a couple elements. You
might have a little joke that you say
that's entertaining in itself, but then
you have a point that you'll make, which
might lead to something else. We have to
answer the next question, which is,
"What's the point of education?" The
point of education is to change
behavior, right? Like, you don't put
your kid in school so that they act the
same. You put their kid in school so
they can start reading or they can start
writing or they can start speaking or
they start doing math. They can change
behavior, right?
And so, uh the stakes are significantly
lower for B2C educator. So, imagine uh a
girl who's doing a hair tutorial or a
makeup tutorial or a a fitness thing for
diet or for working out or somebody
who's giving maybe relationship advice.
The reason that I say it's lower risk is
that let's say you start the diet and it
doesn't work as well. It's not the end
of the world, right? If you buy some
lash extensions and it doesn't work as
well, not the end of the world. Now, can
these people drive sales? Absolutely. I
mean, Huda Beauty built an empire off of
just this concept, right? And the thing
is is that she had credibility within
that domain because she could
demonstrate it live, right? She actually
used the product. You see a before and
after in real time using the implement.
You say, "I'm willing to take this
risk." And so, you do it. Now, AI
will be best suited
to interrupt the stuff on this side. Why
is that? Because if you see a clip of an
AI avatar girl who's doing her lashes or
doing her hair and giving you tips on
how to do it, the likelihood that you'll
listen to it even if it's AI is probably
decently high as long as the stuff seems
like it makes sense. You may be like,
"Oh, I didn't know that. Maybe I'll give
that a shot, right?" Now, as you move
along this continuum, when the stakes
get higher, you're less and less likely
to listen to someone who does not have
third-party proof that's as
demonstrable. So, I'll explain. So, this
middle tier here would be what I would
consider a kind of B2 prosumer.
All right? So, this is kind of where you
get into your
uh money stuff. So, you look at people
who talk about savings and uh investing
money. That's like is there certainly
more risk to what you do with your
savings and your money and investing
than uh lashes and your hair and maybe
even a diet? Ask most people, the answer
probably be yes, right? So, if you look
at some of the top creators in the
space, like let's think of some of them.
So, you've got like Erica taught me,
who's done an awesome job. Now, why do
people listen to her? Because she talks
about how to like make disputes and ask
for refunds. It's all about money. What
is she? She's an attorney, right? She
has more real-world credibility. What's
another example?
Um Vivian Tu. So, she's a uh she's also
she's uh somebody came from finance and
so she has that credibility of kind of
Wall Street, etc. And so she's leveraged
that and she talks about saving and
investing and stuff. Uh you think about
like Dave Ramsey, right? He obviously
has his big business success, uh which
has big overlay on this and he's
obviously been doing this for a really
long time. So, for each of these people,
there's a little bit more proof that's
required. Now, are there people who are
making uh content in the space that have
zero proof?
Maybe. Are they the biggest? No. Why?
Because listening to their advice is
riskier than listening to somebody who
has some visible proof. Hey guys, real
quick, many of you guys are getting
started in business and don't know, but
other entrepreneurs have already tried
to help. And so, 3.6 million copies were
donated by other entrepreneurs in my
book launch and I'm donating these books
as well. And so, if you're starting in
business and you would like the ultimate
business backpack, all three books, this
one shows you how to figure out what to
sell, this shows you how to get people
to find out about it, and this one shows
you how to make money from it. When you
have all three, you can actually get
started. All right, on top of that, you
have 30 days of school that you can get
absolutely free and all of this,
including the books, including school,
including shipping, is 16 bucks. Yeah,
like we lose money on this. So, go grab
it. Um
it's the ultimate thing I can give you,
my gift. Uh enjoy. Um if you go there
and it's shut down, it's cuz we ran out,
but as long as the link still works,
there's books. So, as we move along the
continuum, we have our
B2B creators, right? And so, I would
consider myself in this category
for a lot of my content, this included.
I started this video by saying that we
have over 20 million plus subscribers,
followers, etc. across platform because
I have to give some credibility as to
what I'm saying, right? Now, me giving
credibility around that an AI could
totally replicate because if an AI has a
lot of followers, for example, then that
AI would be able to talk about it
because it would have proof about it.
That all makes sense. Now, if an AI is
saying, "Hey, do this thing in your
business." until there are AIs that have
built
gigantic companies that no human was
involved in, then the likelihood that
the AI will have the ability to gain the
trust of the audience so that they
listen to the advice goes down. Right?
And so like why do we actually care
about proof or demonstration in general
to begin with, right? Well, we take it
as a signal to decrease our own personal
risk.
And so if you have two people that
you're listening to, one person that
just GPT'd, "Hey, this is six things you
need to do to scale your sales team."
never sold anything in their life, never
built a sales team, versus somebody
who's built 10 sales teams and says,
"Here are six things that you need to
do." If the content was the same, which
one of these two people do you think
would have significantly larger
followings? This one. Why?
Because people can actually believe it.
They're actually willing to take action
on it because they'll say, "Okay, this
guy probably knows what he's talking
about because he's done this in the real
world." Now, there is a little bit of
chicken and egg of the the six things
this guy comes up with versus the six
things this guy's come up with. These
ones will probably be a little bit
better because he has in the trenches
knowledge and so there is a little bit
of chicken and egg, but assuming the
information was literally identical, the
person who has the most credibility wins
and not just by a little bit, by a lot
of it. Like why is Elon the number one
business influencer in the world?
Because he's the richest man in the
world, right? And so
it will be it is it will be increasingly
difficult for AI to create the proof
required for B2B and higher-risk types
of content.
And so when we think about this, you're
like, "How do I make my brand or build
my brand in a world where AI can
duplicate anything?"
Well, we have to focus on proof. We You
to focus demonstration. And if we're
looking at this continuum, the more
you're this way,
probably the safer you are at least in
the short-to-medium term. Underneath of
that, we get the next question, which
is, "Okay,
if that is indeed the case, what do I
need to do in order to create content at
scale that can compete with AI?"
Well, it's going to come down to, "How
can I do demonstration
at scale? How can I provide proof at
scale in real time?" For sure, it's
great to have accomplishments,
accomplishments you can mention, right?
You can say them one time, people can
know that you sold a company or or
you're scaled or you're doing $250
million a year in revenue, whatever it
is, right?
You can have that stuff.
But, demonstrating in real time is
something that is incredibly difficult
to fake, right? Now, is there a world in
the future where AI can can can can take
calls? Absolutely, it's probably a year
or two away. It's not even that It's not
even that far.
Maybe by the end of this year. But, to
what are you going to do today, like
watching this video? Well, I'm going to
give you a couple things that have
worked really well for me.
So, number one is, instead of saying,
"Hey, uh you know, of course you want to
do epic and then document it and
then do more epic and then document
it." That's uh no no question. That
would be more of a content creation
method. So, it's like you look at your
calendar, you look at all your meetings,
you put a plug-in for each of the
meetings because you do them virtually,
so you transcribe them, then you say,
"Hey AI, tell me the interesting moments
from these meetings." And then you can
talk about them. So, rather than you
making up stories, you actually give
real examples, right? That is further
along this proof-to-risk spectrum. So,
that's a good thing. But, is there
something that's even better than that?
And I think there is, which is, is there
a way that you can engineer within your
existing business motion, which is, "How
do you service customers of whatever it
is that you sell,
that you can bake in components of
proof?"
So, how how would that work?
Well, if I were selling hair extensions,
I would probably have sweepstakes and
lottery tickets inside of the hair,
which then creates a marketing motion
that I can put around it, which why not?
Then the winners I can call in person to
come to my salons where I can install
them for them. And then all of a sudden
I've got this beautiful loop, a
self-licking ice cream cone if you will,
of I sell, you know, customers come in,
they buy products, those products
generate marketing, that marketing gets
more customers, those customers buy more
products, and around and around we go.
That is a self-licking ice cream cone,
and you want to install it at every
business you have, especially in light
of AI where proof is going to matter
more than anything else. If you're in a
B2B setting, it works the same way. Now,
if you're like, "Oh, well, I, you know,
this doesn't work for my business."
You're not going to make it, dude. I I
don't know what to tell you. Like
if you can't think, "How could I
engineer a way
for me to interact with my customers so
that we could demonstrate the value of
the products that we have in a real
way?"
I don't know what to tell you. Like I'm
trying to think of like the the most
basic, you know, version of this. It's
like all consumer products are really
straightforward. Like literally use the
product. That's I mean it's that's
that's that's it's that simple, right?
On the B2B side, it's going to be more
around the
proof that you can demonstrate around,
let's say you're, you know, obviously
your marketing agency. Okay, bring
someone in, walk through the campaign,
bring the customer in, and show it,
right? Even if you're a small agency, do
it with all your customers. Why not,
right? And worst case scenario, you make
a marketing motion that's Let's say you
only have 10 customers. Okay, start
doing these these audits for people for
free and document them. That's the
trade. Hey, let me do a a whole bunch of
work for free, I'll document it, and
I'll just give it away. Who says no to
that?
Right? The big point here, zooming all
the way out, is that AI is going to
disrupt disproportionately the lowest
risk to the higher risk people in that
order. To protect yourself, you want to
do things that AI will be more difficult
for AI to do. Now, is there a world
where AI can literally do everything?
Probably.
Uh are we there yet? No. And so, in the
meantime, what do you do? You win with
what you got, right? Which is we
demonstrate our expertise and the
quality of our products and services in
front of people ideally to our customers
which we document and if you don't have
enough customers to do it you do it for
everybody publicly.
That's the game that I think is going to
keep you ahead of the pack of AI GPT
avatar driven content because the proof
is going to be in the pudding and you
want to make sure that you've got your
first spoon in. I've talked publicly
about my whole content strategy is live
and interactive. That's what I'm doing.
I'm showing you my cards. I'm telling
you what I'm doing. All right, and so
there's two types of content that you'll
be seeing more and more of and I'm
trying to engineer more and more
components of this into my existing
business so that I can document while I
deliver so that it's no extra added
time, right? Cuz it's like how does how
does Alex make so much content? It's the
reality is that like I'm usually not
making content. We're just capturing it.
Right? That's what allows me to do so
much more volume. And so if you're
thinking to you it's like like if you
have to sit down to actively record
every single thing and you want to make
20 pieces 50 pieces of content a day
you're going to do nothing but stand in
front of the camera. That's going to be
really miserable for you, right? But if
you do what you like doing like for me I
love doing Q&A's with business owners.
It's a lot of I've I've had a lot of
reps with it and I just like it fills me
up, right? And so in person when we have
events if I have time I go downstairs
and I take questions. I can't do it all
the time but whenever there is an event
that's happening and I if I have a blank
calendar I'm going to try and get down
there, right? If I do like today when I
do a recording I'm going to take calls
from people who are in our our newly
launched million dollar plus community
for business owners, right? And so all
of this is like how can I feed the proof
machine? Proof is both the third party
these things have happened. That's the
big exits, the revenue, all that like
head count whatever. I have this many
companies.
And then there's the demonstration side
of it which is
um
can I see this person use their
expertise in real life? Now to be clear
this is a
this is
hardcore more along the services side
but you can still do a demonstration
with products. You would just physically
demonstrate them rather than using your
hands to do whatever service you have.
And so hopefully that gives you at least
a handful of ideas to think through
like, not just oh well, I just sit in
front of a computer all day, there's no
way I can like document what I'm doing.
It's like, yeah, you got to create the
opportunity. No And so,
hold a sweepstakes, hold a
a very limited thing where you email
your whole list and say, "Hey." Or you
just take the 10 customers or five
customers you got right now, go to their
houses. Like, of course there's a way to
do it. Um it just takes work, but you
said you wanted to win. So, welcome to
the game.